k
[Música]
Olá boa noite a todos é um prazer estar
com vocês
novamente vamos responder as suas
dúvidas e discutir casos aí que sejam
interessantes para vocês eu acho que
hoje não vai dar tempo de discutir
artigo porque tem bastante pergunta mas
a gente pode tomar essa decisão aqui no
final
Ok boa
noite Dea mudar aqui o layout aqui pera
aí não é esse le que eu quero esse aqui
isso boa noite Ivanete Boa noite Carlos
Boa noite
Eliane Antônio Renato rubert TAM
miquinha bem Vamos abrir aqui o o
documento com as perguntas da Live de
hoje
aqui está Deixa eu só mudar aqui o
layout
Prontinho pergunta vou tomar o
Albendazol você recomenda um comprimido
por três pera aí essa pergunta aqui é da
Live do dia 19 desculpe tem que abrir
outro documento aqui aborta
Vamos abrir outro documento esse aqui é
o da semana
passada ah perguntas
aquiar
ok apresentar
Agora sim agora tá
certo esse overlay é
melhor eu sempre me enrolo com esses
overlays
aqui mas acho que esse aqui é o melhor
não não esse
aqui é vamos deixar esse overi mesmo
aqui
caro Doutor além do potássio existem
outras variáveis que influenciam na
ocorrência de câimbras uma pessoa que
conheço tem potássio muito bom no
sangue mas tem muita facilidade em ter
câimbras nas panturrilhas e pés pessoa
na terceira idade que faz exercícios
diariamente então além do potássio pode
ser sódio pode ser cálcio pode ser
magnésio tá são esses três minerais os
principais fora o que você falou né
então é potássio sódio Magnésio e cálcio
são quatro minerais
importantes primeiramente é importante
entender que as câimbras são contraturas
musculares repentinas e
dolorosas desidratação além dos
equilíbrios desses quatro minerais que
eu acabei de falar é muito importante
então a pessoa que tá desidratada também
pode ter câimbra então de novo falta de
potássio falta de sódio falta de falta
de Magnésio e ou desidratação
OK outra coisa que pode acontecer se
fazer um exercício muito intenso e você
não fez o preparo você não fez uma um
bom alongamento isso também pode ser um
gatilho de
cra fazer exercício em condições de de
calor extremo também pode levar
desidratação e levar com
consequentemente a câimbra
diuréticos que fazem você perder esses
minerais que eu acabei de falar também
pode ser um gatilho para câimbra
pessoas que TM insuficiência renal
hipotiroidismo ou neuropatia periférica
também essas doenças podem servir como
gatilhos para câimbras até agora eu
falei desidratação dos quatro minerais
falei de não fazer
o preparo correto né não fazer
alongamento falei dessas doenças renal
hipotiroidismo neuropatia
periférica Ok calor extremo causando
desidratação então para evitar fazer o
alongamento adequado antes da atividade
física manter uma hidratação adequada e
manter esses quatro minerais adequados
no seu organismo ok
próxima pergunta a pregnenolona está
liberada para manipulação em Venda não
está já houve épocas que sim então Teve
uma época que foi proibido depois as
farmácias
conseguiram reverter isso aí proibiram
de novo aí as famas reverteram e agora
no atual momento estamos no momento da
proibição você só consegue comprar
pregnenolona
importada da internet OK
próxima
pergunta usamos muito alho por aqui
revisando seus vídeos vi que existem
outras opções como em pó desidratado e o
óleo preto que parece meio adocicado
minha mulher diz que não fazem efeito
como o tempero são uma boa opção para
substituir pelo óleo
fresco na verdade ela tem uma certa
razão O alho em pó desidratado ele pode
ser interessante para questões de
armazenamento ele é conveniente mas ele
perde um pouco do Sabor e do aroma
intenso e a desidratação pode fazer
reduzir os compostos ativos benéficos
como
alicina o alho preto é o alho fermentado
é muito bom pro coração o sistema
arterial ele é obtido através de um
processo de fermentação que muda a
textura sabor então ele tem um sabor
mais suave mais toxicado como você
falou e pode ser uma boa opção para quem
não gosta do Sabor forte Doo fresco e oo
Preto ele retém e concentra vários
compostos ativos
benéficos né então ele fica com poder
antioxidante mais forte devido à
fermentação o alo preto pode ser uma
opção se você gostar do Sabor ou você
pode misturar o alho Fresco com alho
Preto aí você vai ter o benefício do
Sabor e o benefício dos antioxidantes do
Óleo preto ou ainda você pode usar o
óleo fresco na culinária e usar o alho
Preto somente como recurso terapêutico
então você pode tomar cápsula de alho
preto e não utilizar ele como tempero e
usar o alho fresco como tempero beleza
Ficou
claro quem fez essa pergunta
foi o Carlos ketman Eu acho que ele não
entrou na Live ainda não el entrou sim
você tá acompanhando então Carlos você
tem alguma outra pergunta de segmento
Deu para
entender a resposta bem temos uma outra
pergunta da
Iane Teria algum efeito benéfico em
fazer um rodízio entre metiformina e
berberina por exemplo usar TRS meses um
e TR meses o outro eu nunca usei assim
eles
têm esses dois compostos TM semelhanças
aí no modo de
ação tanto a m formina quanto a beberina
tem o efeito de ativar a MK que é a
proteína kinasa ativada por Amp eentão
ativando a MPK isso tem mecanismo
antienvelhecimento tem mecanismo de
melhorar a sensibilidade à insulina
reduzindo a
Glicemia Eu geralmente eu passo os dois
juntos eu não faço essa alternância e
não conheço ninguém esteja fazendo essa
alternância mas Teoricamente poderia ser
benéfico Sim essa alternância eu só
nunca testei fazer
isso então é Teoricamente factível
apesar que eu nunca tenha feito
Geralmente eu associo os dois e não faço
isso alternado mas não vejo nenhum
problema em fazer desse jeito ok
Eu acho que o efeito mais benéfico seria
associar os dois em vez de fazer
alternado
sabe Mas como eu disse não sou contra
esse conceito
não pergunta isso aqui eu não tenho o
nome de quem
perguntou desde a publicação do seu
vídeo adotamos o uso do cominho Preto
Naquele tempo era difícil de achar e
caríssimo hoje existem muitas ofertas
mas com variação de preço absurdo algum
critério que possa ser seguido para
comprar bem é importante você verificar
a origem desse cominho
né o cominho preto de melhor qualidade
ele vem de regiões conhecidas por
práticas agrícolas
sustentáveis e condições climáticas
favoráveis
a Índia por exemplo é um ótimo produtor
de cominho preto de alta qualidade Então
tenta ver se o cominho que você tá
tentando comprar se ele
vem dessa região aí da Índia Ok Verifica
a embalagem se tá bem embalada A
Conservação então a embalagem hermética
faz diferença ou uma garrafa de vidro
escuro seria também uma boa ideia
escolha um produto que não seja próximo
da data de
validade procure por certificações
orgânicas que seri muito
interessante procure ler avaliações de
outros consumidores
feedbacks não escolho o mais barato
porque isso é um geralmente é um
indicador de que não é de
qualidade e mande um e-mail pro
fornecedor ou uma mensagem pro
fornecedor perguntando informações
sobre a procedência Se o vendedor
entregar essas informações sem muita
pirula é porque provavelmente você pode
confiar se ficar fazendo firula
desconfia e não compra
Ok próxima pergunta da ru Elita a
taurina está indicada para arritmia
cardíaca sim está ajudaria na insônia
Sim ajuda a taurina é aminoácido
sulfonado ele é muito importante pro
detox ele é muito importante também pra
regulação do Ritmo cardíaco pra proteção
contra o estresse
oxidativo então em termos de coração a
taurina ajuda a regular o ritmo cardíaco
mantém a saúde desse
músculo a taurina não pode ajudar a
reduzir a incidência de arritmias
e pode ajudar na insônia também porque a
taurina ele tem um efeito sistema
nervoso central protetor
neuroprotetor ajuda a aumentar o Gab
reduzir a ansiedade reduzir o
estresse então ele ele é um bom
adjuvante aí pro sono eu eu geralmente
eu uso a taurina junto com a teanina
junto com a glicina junto com a lisina
junto
com ervas indutoras de sono junto com a
a própria melatonina né então a taurina
É bem interessante sim por cima nervoso
central e ajuda a acalmar e induzir o
sono
Ok
ã eu não sei porque que tá tá subindo
isso aqui toda
vez declina auditivo idoso teria algo
para reverter Ou pelo menos reduzir o
progressão da
perda olha é bem difícil viu interferir
Nisse quem teve declino auditivo
geralmente você consegue interromper a
piora mas não reverter né É muito
difícil porque isso é dano neurológico
no ouvido
interno então entre as estratégias que
você pode utilizar para reduzir a
progressão melhorar a qualidade de
vida a principal dela sem dúvida é
evitar a exposição a ruídos altos então
usando protetores auricular e ambientes
barulhentos e também não ficar escutando
música alta ok uma dieta rica
antioxidantes com vitamina C
ajudam zinco e magnésio ajuda
as chantin luteína apesar de ser mais
para ôo também ajuda
ovino
interno usar também substância que
melhor a circulação do ovido interno
como Gin cobiloba também pode ajudar
com enzima que 10 Alf lipoico e nac
também podem ser úteis úteis
desculpa tem relatos que a terapia de
oxigenação hiperbárica pode ajudar
tá mas certamente se for sa não vai
autorizar então teria que fazer
particular porque não tá no rol da NS
para esse P
aí se a pessoa fuma ou consome álcool em
excesso amente precisaria rever isso
né existe também terapias fono
audiológicas que ajudam para
reabilitação
auditiva não vai melhorar o ouvido mas
vai ajudar a melhorar a compressão de
fala e adaptação ao uso de dispositivos
auditivos que muitos casos é muito
necessário existe estudos mostrando que
pessoas que não escutam direito ou que
não enxergam direito Elas têm muito mais
propensão a déficit cognitivo alsheimer
então um idoso que não está vendo bem ou
não está ouvindo bem precisa cuidar das
duas situações para não ter queda
cognitiva
Ok comecei a tomar celeno 200 ué pulou
de novo esse negócio fica pulando aqui
cara comecei a tomar Selen 200 mg e
percebi que estava sentindo dor no
fígado Uai quadrante superior direito
então de uzir que deveria ser do Selene
parei de tomar isso pode acontecer a
dosagem está correta a dosagem em si tá
correta entre 100 e 200 microg por dia
Ok se você tiver tomando ess há muito
muito tempo mesmo pode ser que ele
acumulou e causou algum nível de
toxicidade mas geralmente sintomas são
dor abdominal de modo geral Não
especificamente num quadrante superior
direito também nause e diarreia mas é
possível sim que o celen em exesso possa
causar dano ao
fígado se você parou de tomar o celen e
a dor diminuiu é provável que seja por
causa do selênio que você tomou talvez
por tempo
demais porque a dose não tá alta então
pode ser uma uma dose que foi
cumulativa e a melhor forma de chear
isso é com exame de função hepática
exame de imagem no fígado para confirmar
se de fato você teve problema nesse
órgão Tá mas possível é totalmente
possível que tenha acontecido por conta
do selênio tá a dosagem não está alta
mas se você usou muito tempo pode ser
que acumulou e você teve uma sobrecarga
de
selênio tomei azul de metileno por
alguns dias porém como tenho varizes
achei que não foi uma boa Associação as
varizes começaram a me incomodar se não
fosse isso teria continuado Nunca vi
ninguém reclamar disso que AZ un de
metileno tenha piorado varizes o aul de
metileno é Vaso constritor ou vaso
dilatador ele tem um efeito bloqueador
de óxido nítrico mas é suave
tá então por bloquear o óxido nítrico
Teoricamente poderia ser vaso constritor
mas na prática eu não vejo isso uma vez
assisti uma live não me lembro o nome do
entrevistado que disse especialista azul
de metilen disse que o único azul de
metilen que faz efeito cognitivo de
micropartículas pois os outros tipos não
atravessam a barreira e Mat cefálica
isso tá com muita cara de ser alguém
querendo vender produto
tá cria aa sensação de autoridade para
vender o produto que só dele que que
serve no meu caso não achei que fiquei
mais inteligente mas meu humor e
comunicação melhoraram Isso é uma forma
de melhorar a inteligência né melhorar a
comunicação
é um tipo de inteligência
comunicação pois eu falo pouco e passei
a falar mais sendo assim acredito que
azul de metileno teve algum efeito no
sistema nervoso tô correta sim se teve
teve um efeito eu acho improvável que
tenha sido o azul de metileno que causou
pior nas varizes tá
então além do que eu já falei que
Teoricamente a de metileno por ser um
bloqueador de óxido nítrico causaria
vaso construção o relato que nós temos
em baixo dosagem que geralmente é o que
eu considero é que ele é vaso dilatador
tá e não vaso
constritor eu acho que se essa pessoa
que tá falam que é especialista em azul
de metileno tem que ver se ela tá
vendendo azul de metileno tá se ela não
tá vendendo aí aumenta a credibilidade
dela mas eu acho que AZ me não vai
passar a barreira Independente de ser
micropartícula ou
não mas como eu falei eu nunca vi lugar
nenhum que poderia piorar varizes tá mas
se você não se deu bem com azul de
metileno não use
semana passada perguntei sobre a
possibilidade de ingerir beber óleo de
Castanha tem tem algum óleo que sem ser
o óleo de coco que seja rico em
nutrientes que eu posso tomar mais sem
risco de
histamina Maria leen que tá perguntando
isso ol de semente cheia é uma boa opção
en rico em ômega-3 especialmente o alfa
linolênico
oo de linhaça também não sendo
processado né em alta temperatura tanto
a chia quanto a linhaça é bom que seja
óleo ex prensado a
frio o óleo também de linhaça dá suporte
à função
digestiva óleo de nós também é uma opção
interessante nenhum desses aí são ricos
em estamina
tá sempre escolha óleos que que sejam
produzidos com método de extração suave
prensado a frio
Ok Isso vai ser o mais
importante Doutor existe um médico que
tem um canal no YouTube está fazendo uma
série de vídeos sobre abordagem
tratamento metabólico dos do câncer ele
irá ministrar um curso de 4 dias caso o
doutor tenha interesse o link é integral
functional medicine service page how to
implement metabolic therapy tem
interesse sim inclusive vou até abrir
esse arquivo agora aqui abrir essa link
esse link agora aqui deixa eu
ver auto implement metabolic
therapy então aí caiu nessa página aqui
tá cobrando 50 pelo curso
ele tá comprando aqui não tá gratuito
não viu mas eu vou estudar eu achei
interessante isso
aqui muito obrigado
viu sempre que vocês acharem materiais
Assim vocês podem me mandar
viu É mas você não colocou o cara
gratuito Você só colocou que ele está
fazendo um curso de 4
dias mas aí o dólar tá indo para R 6 né
6 x 300 e 49
350 vai dar para quase r$ 2000 É mas às
vezes vale a
pena Doutor um paciente que já teve
câncer de próstata Passou pela retirada
do órgão e 15 Anos Depois apresenta PSA
de se um nódulo onde era Originalmente a
próstata isso é recidiva da doença ao
realizar radioterapia qual seria o tempo
esperado o número de sessões de
radioterapia geralmente são 28 a 30
sessões que teria de fazer para notar a
queda do
PSA pode demorar meses tá se meses
depois da rádio pro PSA cair se eu não
fizer outro tipo de tratamento como
bloqueio
hormonal o esperado é ao final da
rádioterapia o pensar zerar novamente
zerar não vai mas eu esperado que fique
abaixo de 0,1 ou 0,2 tá
Doutor a respeito do Terceiro Congresso
novas ciências Você viu meu post né
referente a apresentação sobre biofísica
na saúde deixa eu ser sincero com vocês
aquele post lá foi mais
para como se diz jogar confete tá porque
na verdade eu fui só no sábado eu não
assisti aula nenhuma praticamente não
assisti sim assisti só
uma aula e meia lá do no sábado então eu
não vi essa aula
aí tá eu fui lá mais para conversar com
o Rodrigo 25 com o Ícaro e para
interagir com outras pessoas eu não vi
praticamente nenhuma palestra eu só vi
uma palestra do Alexandre Távola e uma
lá
da da Pinheiro lá da menina que fala
muito de parasita
elizabe Pinheiro
eh referente à apresentação sobre
formulações frequenciais vale a pena
pagar mais caro em manipulados
frequencias Ótima
pergunta existe evidência que comprove a
eficácia do tratamento se tem evidência
eles não mostram viu é bem empírico o
negócio é bem
empírico supostamente seria melhor mas
eles não dão trabalho científico né só
só relato de boca mesmo referente a
apresentação sobre um caso Clínico de
câncer de próstata poderia nos
apresentar não eu não eu não vi essa
apresentação então não eu não fui lá
para ver a as palestras como eu tô
dizendo para
vocês então vou pular essa outra
pergunta aqui
também você disse em um vídeo passado
que se uma pessoa beber dois copos de
água assim que acordar e antes de dormir
pode evitar infarto com férie sim vai
hidratação isso é um dos fatores que
pode proteger contra o infarto uma
pessoa bem hidratada pode evitar
entupimento das artérias sim mas não é
só isso né é uma das coisas mais simples
você pode fazer para evitar o infarto tá
o que causa insuficiência renal como
evitar a falta de hidratação é uma das
causas sim existe uma insistência renal
cham pré-renal e a principal causa da
pré-renal é a falta de hidratação é a
principal provavelmente a principal
sim vi na internet na Iá do Google
falando que não que a falta de água não
evita a insuficiência
renal que a falta de água não
evita ficou mal escrito né isso aqui né
não a falta de água é uma causa iní
renal então não entendi que você quis
dizer que falando que não não há falta
de água não
evita Bem Além
da insf renal pré-renal que é por
desidratação outras causas bem comuns é
diabetes e pressão
alta em pessoas mais jovens uma causa
comum também é glomer
nefrite quando é grave né e não não
consegue ser controlada com cortic imun
pressor uso de antiinflamatórios eh não
esteroidais né os antiinflamatórios
comuns também é uma causa muito comum de
insuficiência
renal exposição a toxinas como metais
pesados como mercúrio pode danificar os
rins Como chumbo também pielonefrite que
infecção do Rim é uma causa um pouco
menos frequente mas também é uma causa
renal obstruções né existe esp renal pós
renal que é por obstrução que que pedra
nos zins que entope os dois ureteres ou
uma próstata extremamente aumentada
também pode causar
isso então são essas as
causas principais
Ok eu diria que as três principais
causas São diabetes pressão alta uso de
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais são as
três principais causas de renal e talvez
a desidratação seja a
quarta exames para saber a saúde renal
de uma forma geral você pode usar a
ureia a creatinina que são os exames de
rotina alguns pacientes vale a pena
pedir a cistatina c Por exemplo porque
tem casos de pessoas que usam a creatina
e aumenta a creatinina não confundam
creatina com creatinina o uso do
suplemento
creatina pode aumentar a creatinina Ok e
não é nesse
caso causa de insuficiência
renal então creatinina e vrea são os
marcadores do dia a dia cistatina C em
caso de dúvida e casos aí que você quer
confirmar também você pode fazer né a
depuração da filtração glomerular né o
teste de clearance de creatinina ok
também interessante fazer exame para ver
presença de proteína na urina
microalbuminúria na urina de 24 horas
ver como é que tá a glicose do sangue
glicose na urina também ok exam de mág
como tração renal e
tomografia bus casos ressonância nuclear
magnética seriam esses os principais
perguntei no WhatsApp se similar não é
silimarina né tá errado aqui silimarina
fazia mal rim se a pessoa tivesse
problema renal e você disse Depende do
estado da doença a silimarina não
similar é contraindicado Em que
situações situação que você esteja com a
inícia renal mais grave
tá então se você tiver umaa renal grau
três já estaria contraindicado a
silimarina OK agora esse renal leve não
é contraindicado
não Quais são os benefícios da dieta
cetogênica e poderia ter para mulheres
que têm acima de 50 anos que tem miomas
de 5
cm Olha nunca vi dieta cetogênico
resolver mioma não vi no Google em
inglês algumas notícias falando que pode
desmanchar nunca vi acontecer isso
e paran nódulos no seio
benignos vai desinflamar a pessoa de
modo geral a dieta cetogênica agora
desfazer mioma e cisto de mama eu acho
muito Improvável
no caso mioma e cisto de mama a gente
usa mais o iodo né durante uns dois anos
pode ajudar a reduzir mas a de
cetogênica vai ser um bom auxílio aí mas
não vai desfazer sozinho
não tá então usaria a dieta cetogênica
para desinflamar o corpo como um todo
para melhorar a função cerebral mas sen
não para desfazer e sozinho nem nódulo
de mama
ou cisto de mama e tampouco o mioma tá
aí no caso é melhor utilizar o iodo kelp
para
isso mas mesmo assim vai demorar um
tempão né mas não vai desfazer vai
diminuir o
tamanho você falou certa vez que tem
cânceres que se alimentam de gordura
para esse a dieta cetogênica ainda seria
útil não não seria
nesse caso não vai adiantar fazer
cetogênica porque o tumor vai pegar o a
gordura como fonte de
energia mas graças a Deus esse tipo de
tumor é bem menos comum a maioria dos
tumores ele é mais dependente de glicose
infelizmente as coisas não tão são
simples assim
né se uma pessoa tem meta de 3 meses com
cetose para remissão de diabetes eem um
dia ela quebra a dieta mas no outro ela
reinicia ela perdeu os dias anteriores
perdeu dependendo do da quantidade de
dias que ela quebrou ela perdeu
sim tá então tem que fazer tem que ser
consistente na dieta
tá então se digamos faz dois dias de
dieta e quebra no terceiro dia não vai
adiantar Quase nada tá mas é importante
não desanimar e voltar pro pra
rotina O que fazer quando a um sist de
22 não baixa de forma nenhuma a pessoa
usa todos os artifícios disponíveis no
mercado não baixa mthfr elit Tero zigoto
qual
snip B9 metilado trimetilglicina Colina
vitamina B2
vitamina B6 ativada né perox sal C
fosfato e nada faz efeito e o zinco 68
não sobe de forma nenhuma então o zinco
baixo pode ser a causa dessa alta tá e
pode ser também problema de Rin isso daí
pode ser problema de funcionamento do
rim e o Zin 68 não sobe de forma nenhuma
mesmo usando alta dose de bisglicinato
Zico iônico estranho isso daí hein
Então essa pessoa tá com problema de
absorção de mineral né então teria que
fazer esse zinco
endovenoso quem tem a Alfa anti triptina
baixa do valor de referência como
aumentar
uma coisa que poderia mentar essa
absorção de Zinco é o uso do cuidade
betaína
viu aí ajudar a ionizar o zinco para ser
absorvido em relação a essa pergunta da
Alfa antitripsina você pode tá dando
suporte pro fígado e nesse caso tende a
aumentar a produção de Alf um antist
tripsina
então taurina que eu já comentei aqui na
live vitamina C vitamina e selênio
vários aminoácidos aí o nac glicina eh
os tocotrienóis podem ajudar a proteger
o
fígado então pode ser que essa micina
esteja alta por causa do Zin que não
está conseguindo o repor tá uma opção
seria usar o coloridade betaína e outra
opção seria usar os o zinco endovenoso a
gordura do Óleo de coco e do azeite de
oliva ela serve para dar energia sim
serve
eh e assim substituir algum alimento da
dieta cetogênica Sim pode ser não
substituir né complementar
né se uma pessoa comer três ou quatro
colheres de azeite de oliva e duas de
óleo de coco por dia e comer saladas com
brócolis alface abacate ela pode se
sustentar Lógico que
sim tem que fazer um cálculo de caloria
também né durante o tempo da dieta já
que excesso de proteína da carne gera
carboidrato ela gera glicose né pode
acontecer de gerar glicose sim
mas de qualquer maneira mesmo que a
proteína vai virar glicose cuidado né
também não vai baixar demais a proteína
porque é um problema né você tem que
comer pelo menos 1 g kil dia de proteína
aí para ter proteí suficiente para
construção das células né
gostaria de saber qual o melhor
suplemento para acabar com a fadiga Neva
cerebral causada pelo
hipotiroidismo a melhor maneira é
repondo os hormônios tiroidianos
né mas fora a reposição dos hormônios
tiroidianos a ch Ganda é um bom
suplemento para dar suporte à saúde
tiroidiana shanda ele tem um efeito
positivo na tireoide a vitamina D tem um
efeito positivo o zinco o cobre o as
vitaminas do complexo B O
selênio o ferro para quem tem
deficiência de Ferro o próprio
magnésio ômega3 pode ajudar também com
enzima que1
probióticos e para quem tem deficiência
de iodo o próprio iodo né
estou tendo dificuldade de encontrar
alimentos que se encaixem na dieta
cetogênica minhas opções são
abacate carne de
frango carne de boi ovelha óleo de coco
aceito de oliva e verduras de uma uma
forma geral e ovo de galinha esses
alimentos por si só é capaz de manter
uma pessoa em cetose sim mas sim é é
possível mas tem vários outros vegetais
você pode estar ingerindo tá
Por que tá tendo dificuldade de
encontrar alimentos que se encaixem você
já leu algum livro sobre dieta
cetogênica o que você colocou aí tá
correto
né É só você aumentar sua variedade de
vegetais né tudo que você colocou aí tá
correto
por favor poderia disponibilizar a lista
de alimentos permitidos na dieta
cetogênica vou mandar no grupo
tá a carne de frango ela pode você
consumir todos os dias na dieta
cetogênica pode carne vermelha eu
recomendo você coma duas vezes por
semana tá
mas deixa eu dar uma uma geral óleo de
coco azeite de oliva óleo de abacate o
próprio abacate nós e castanhas Semente
de abóbora sem de irassol manteiga
clarificada óleo de niao óleo de chia né
como eu já comentei hoje aqui carnes em
geral mas carne vermelha duas vezes
semana
cí se for a da casem na dois né duas
vezes semana
também legumes que crescem acima do solo
né que tem baixo Teo de
carboidrato frutas também vermelhas
açaí banana que não amadureceu
completamente né no caso kiwi também
maçã e perira mutação
mas eu passo a dieta completa no grupo
tá antes de dormir urina transparente no
outro dia aou acordar urina amarela isso
é normal né você dormiu ficou várias
horas dormindo concentra a urina né
primeira urina do dia vai ser sempre
concentrada é sinal de desidratação é
sinal de desidratação relativa né porque
você ficou 8 horas sem tomar água ou 7
horas você tomar
água beber pouca água beber pouca água
não causa insuficiência renal não é
verdade os in se ajustam à situação de
privação de
água bem se você é de uma linhagem aí
genética de beduínos no deserto pode até
acontecer isso mas para pessoas normais
aqui que moram no Brasil se você beber
pouca água ficar hidratado por muito
tempo é causa sim de desidratação é
causa sim de insuficiência renal cansei
de ver em pronto socorro
tá no entanto a desidratação crônica que
é isso que eu tô falando né obviamente
pode levar a danos progressivos nos
tecidos renais isso cência renal né
então a ia errou aí e contribuir para o
desenvolvimento de doenças renais
crônicas a ingestão de água de qualidade
é fundamental pro bom funcionamento dos
zins a quantidade recomendada de água a
beber por dia depende do peso da pessoa
pode variar de 2 a 3 L tá correto a
hidratação correta ajuda a eliminar
bactérias ureza do trato urinário Tá
então não sei qual que é a sua pergunta
aí mas a pergunta seria se urina
concentrado de manhã é sinal de
desidratação é uma desidratação leve mas
que não vai levar problemas no rim não
tá todos os miomas uterinos podem ser
desmanchados pela medicina natural não
não existe nunca seja qual for a
medicina não existe sempre e não existe
nunca
tá isso é uma regra fundamental da
Medicina ou tem que ter intervenção
cirúrgica nem sempre você fazer
intervenção cirúrgica mesmo que não
desmanche com o iodo por exemplo se a
pessoa uma mulher entrou na menopausa
geralmente o mioma vai murchar sozinho
tá
gast se for emocional pode ser tratada
com suplemento
pode gastrite seja qual for a origem
pode ser tratada com suplemento
sim você pode utilizar licorice né
dgl o próprio Aloe Vera né que a
desculpa mamona não é o Aloe Vera é o
não é mamona desculpa é
o fugiu agora babosa babosa né
o Zin carnosina ajuda
bastante gengibre ajuda cúrcuma ajuda né
Tem uma falma de cúrcuma que é de baixa
absorção que é boa para
isso
ok tintura de guaçatonga tintura
de espinheira santa né também ajuda
bastante que quem faz a dieta cetogênica
tem crise de abstinência de
Açúcar pode acontecer no começo sim
eh existe a Ketu né que é a gripe
cetogênica que você fica com dor de
cabeça com mal estar
desidratado e para evitar isso daí você
tem que tomar bastante água e comer
bastante desculpa mamão não comer
bastante abacate que vai ter bastante
magnésio
então recapitulando né o ketofol é vai
dar dor de cabeça fadiga desidratação
problemas de concentração náuseas
irritabilidade e você resolve V bebendo
bastante água e tomando os minerais tá
que tem no abacate por
exemplo ou você pode consumir um
suplemento tem magnésio potássio e sódio
né para manter os eletrodos
equilibrados e sal integral né
importante
né devido a problemas com estaminas
padeço muito com entupimento do nariz
então ten um pouco oxigênio aprendi que
prejudico as
mitocôndrias doses maiores de azul de
metileno poderá ajudar
não sei te dizer porque nunca usei para
esse pim
não eu usaria nesse caso que cetina que
é um antistamínico natural e
antiinflamatório
natural vitamina C também ajuda nesse
caso magnésio zinco
probióticos beber bastante água colocar
soro fisiológico no nariz
Tá mas azul de metileno acho que não
ajudaria nesse caso
não o que dá cetose exercício
alimentação e jejum a noite de sono mal
influencia essa frase tá mal de Gida né
e da cetose é jejum atividade física e
alimentação baixa carbohidrato
certo dormir mal atrapalha a cetose ok
Porque aumenta o cortisol porque dormir
mal aumenta o cortisol e aumento do
cortisol pode aumentar a glicose Ok a
beberina é melhor do que a metiformina
para reduzir os níveis de açúcar não
diria que é
melhor não mas ela tem outros efeitos
adicionais que a me fomina não tem tá
então eu usaria os dois juntos ou uma
pessoa que só usa metiformina tá bem
controlada eu usaria a mefina não
precisaria acrescentar berberina mas
berberina tem efeito por exemplo
antioxidante
ela tem efeito também de reduzir as
bactérias do intestino tem um efeito
também modulador de flora intestinal que
é mefina não tem tanto assim
tá também tem mas a mefina tem menos
efeito modulador de intestino do que a
beberina você disse que não é
recomendado correr todos os dias pois
pode causar lesão E o ciclismo pode ser
todo dia
bem o ciclismo ele é considerado de
baixo
Impacto ao contrário da corrida que você
tem bastante Impacto aí nas articulações
joelho quadril coluna
vertebral e o ciclismo se feito com
moderação sim ele pode ser feito
diariamente Ok mas tem que tomar alguns
cuidados não pode se exagerar demais no
tempo de treino
fazer o alongamento adequado antes do
uso da bicicleta é
importante e é bom fazer a musculação
junto para prover a massa das peras
né Med integrativa não existe nada capaz
de R sequelas do AVC caso não tenha
sequela não mas você pode
evitar que o AVC piore né e o sistema
nervoso central consegue se recuperar
até um certo ponto caso não tenha
Hospital especializado para impedir
sequela existe algo que uma pessoa que
saiba que está correndo o risco de AVC
ao menos suspeitando possa fazer bem se
você acha que o teu risco de TVC muito
muito grande Eu não moraria em cidade
interior
tá moraria numa cidade grande
PR prevenção do AVC você sabe que tem
que ter um estilo de vida saudável
máximo que você puder
ok agora uma pessoa que já teve AVC você
pode est metendo ela além de de melhora
o estilo de vida a fisioterapia terapia
ocupacional o tens né que é a
estimulação nervosa transcutânea
ajuda e tem um monte de de suplemento
que dá suporte NV Central né que você
pode ser utilizado para minimizar aí as
consequências do AVC mas não vai
reverter né essa que é a verdade vai só
minimizar o que acontece quas pessoas se
recuperam muito de AVC e conseguem ficar
normais depois é é porque o sistema
nervosocentral tem a plasticidade e
algumas áreas do cérebro consegue
assumir a função do que morreu lá e
então é como se houvesse um
redirecionamento né da função neuronal
para aquela área que não tá comprometida
Então isso é uma recuperação que
acontece algumas pessoas por conta da
neuroplasticidade
Ok bem acabaram as perguntas do
documento deixa eu ver se tem pergunta
ao vivo
aqui o cominho Preto Que que se encontra
é da Turquia o de preço mais
alto os baratos parecem ser daqui o
clima que favorece
eh não eu acho que o cominho preto é
mais de clima temperado como é o caso da
Turquia tá ou o caso de algumas regiões
da
China Boa noite a todos
novamente por que só pode comer carne
vermelha duas vezes na semana porque
existe várias suspeitas em cima da carne
vermelha que não foram totalmente
elucidadas ainda relacionadas a produtos
de glicação avançada relacionado a Minas
heterocíclicas então
até a gente esclarecer isso porque tem
muita gente que defende o consumo diário
né que não dá problema nenhum mas até
ter certeza eu recomendaria comer hum
duas a três vezes semana tá para declin
aditiva
emoso pergunta feita por alguém há pouco
uma boa opção de tratamento é
ozonioterapia auricular como tratamento
eh complementar tá Eliseu poderia ser
uma boa sim
no YouTube você diz que quem for membro
terá acesso a locais onde comprar Nato
orgânico e também receitas culinárias
usando Nat não encontrei na tonelada de
material Eu nem me lembro mais disso viu
Eliseu tem muito tempo já
isso tem certeza que não tá no documento
isso porque na época eu acho que eu
coloquei no documento sim viu
eu vou verificar isso depois eu passo um
feedback para vocês
tá algumas lives atrás você disse que o
pro tem da doctors first possui um
pouquinho de gordura não tô lembrar
disso
não acho que eu tava lendo o rótulo não
é isso Eliseu dá uma lida lá no rótulo
tá do da doctors first
a partir de quanto tempo consumindo o
remédio Tarja vermelha cloridratos
calina a pessoa manifesta os efeitos
colaterais por volta de 15 a 20 dias
geralmente
tá como a remoção da vesícula afeta os
pós
bariátricos afeta porque a emusica das
gorduras fica prejudicada e essa pessoa
vai ter deficiência de vitaminas
lipossolúveis e de algumas gorduras
essenciais tá essa que é o problema da
remoção da vesícula especialmente
bariátricos eu fiz uma tomografia o
técnico recomendou os de contraste é
muito perigoso depende é um contraste
iônico ou não iônico sempre você for
fazer uma tomografia peça para usar o
contraste não iônico que é mais caro mas
é bem mais seguro
tá mas se você fizer só uma vez ou duas
não vai dar problema o iônico não
geralmente não dá mas opte pelo não
iônico Quando você diz que alguns V
Protein possuem gordura você se refere
gordura trans
não é gordura do leite né
é o concentrado tem gordura do leite
porque não foi totalmente isolado o
restante
iodo não iônico tá procura o contraste
não iônico
Ok não
iônico bem pessoal tá bom já né Tem uma
hora de Live
já ficou alguma dúvida das outras
perguntas que eu respondi do
documento eu vou dar um tempo aí de 2
minutos e vou encerrar
tá vou aguardar você se testarem
aí então Eliseu usei Protein
concentrados ele tem a gordura do leite
tá não é gordura trans não mas o isolado
hidrolizado não tem essa gordura
Ok mas lê o rótulo tá eles são obrigados
a colocar isso no rótulo
Estela Mares está ótimo boa
noite bom descanso Obrigado
miquinho há uns anos atrás fo postado no
grupo sobre Ina essa informação tá vendo
Então foi lá que eu coloquei a Denise me
ajudou
aqui acho que eu talvez tenha colocado
no grupo e não coloquei no no YouTube
né Denis se você conseguir resgatar essa
informação você passa pro Eliseu Por
favor
eu vou dar uma olhada no meu computador
também deve estar por
aqui bem muito obrigado a vocês que
assistiram a Live e aos que não
assistiram ao vivo sempre lembrando que
tá tudo gravado e vai sempre ficar
gravado enquanto eu tiver o canal no
YouTube tá abraço até a semana que vem
beijo no coração de vocês